es ist mal wieder so weit würde der bund
hier nicht auf die heute herzlich
willkommen heißen zu einer neuen episode
des formates lupe ja und jetzt noch mal
ein richtiger wird eine blondine nackt
in den garten genau weil die tomaten
dann rot werden
das meinst du nicht ernst
das ziel kommt mit seinen tennis nach
hause und vater fast das 0 6 in deutsch
gibt mit du denkt ihr wirklich dass sie
lustig seid was so rasch und wandert in
den bergen
eine wanderin ich stelle mir gerade in
der wandernde mandarine vor
[Musik]
damen und herren das erste video dieser
web wieso deluca reagiert wo wirklich
mal talent gezeigt wurde
finde ich sehr schön das ist ja das eine
lied von diesem einen künstler
ich kann das tatsächlich auch spielen
[Musik]
ja das war von mir da rede ich gerade
von qualität
da kommt so ein typ der eine roma aus
dem boden schmeißt danke echt mega geil
30 und 16
[Musik]
ja das ist mein neues auto für ein
fahrrad
ich kann den humor wirklich nicht finden
haha ich sprühe luke war 2 die mit dem
ein weil er so stinkt hat er das grab
angezündet ein paar sekunden später riss
im ort rom
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich frag mich bei der luxus wirklich gar
nichts mehr
meine frau ist meine mama eine putzfrau
denn du bist wirklich freude
dankeschön dankeschön dass sie
mittlerweile wirklich da muss ich
wirklich sagen war echt nicht
danke für dein video ford noch ein video
geschickt
auch danke dafür erfreut mich echt mega
seine modellbahn er hat mir noch ein
video geschickt
macht weiter so
ein ritter liegt unterm baum und der
löwe kommt vorbei und sagt schon wieder
dosenfutter also da kriegst du von mir
wirklich dem bringen der woche genau da
will ich das buch geschrieben meine
lieben freunde einfach um es aus dem
fenster zu schmeißen treffen sich zwei
unterhosen sind geeint anderen warum
bist du so kommen sagt die andere städte
eine beschissene woche
was ist eigentlich laut
aha jetzt verstehe ich also ich hab echt
comedypreis verdienst kommt allerdings
auch zum letzten video das sie mit dem
hashtag luca reagiert auf instagram
gepostet hat ich hab das ja nur das
titelbild gesehen das ist nämlich merge
von mir und da bin ich sehr gespannt was
in dem video jetzt passieren wird von
ihm einen kanal oder ich lade 400 wären
auf dein handy move h
[Musik]